would you date a virgin for me
personally I feel like the cons of the
inner virgin is that there's no exes no
[ __ ] no nothing that you know comes
with baggage basically wait that's a con
that is a pro I mean sorry a pro
um but the cons of it could be that
you're dating the sky
this might not be as amazing can I touch
your face for everyone everyone was once
a virgin so yeah that doesn't go to say
that he can't learn the way you would
like to be but you'd have to teach him
right okay you would have to I mean are
you happy are you okay with teaching a
man I mean yeah and I said no just be
real everyone
's seen corn right corn yeah yeah so as
a you already kind of know where corn is
not even close to sexual it's not it's
more exaggerated okay but you kind of
know what you're getting yourself into
right
right okay yeah so obviously he's not
gonna he might not be the best but then
there's guys that actually have maybe a
lot no but I'm asking you a question
like would you prefer would you prefer
to teach a man
let me let's make it a number so would
you would you date a guy with zero
bodies or a guy with say 30 bodies
I would prefer the zero bodies but
but obviously 30 let's say he's older
than you how you said you're 21 yeah so
let's say 30 bodies by he's 35 yeah yeah
35.
that's not bad yeah yeah okay so so
you'd be so which one would you pick
don't know
to be fair I would I'm quite open-minded
with both no no they're the exact same
one has one has sexual experience one
you have to teach who you picking
hmm
I feel like I would just like the fact
that a virgin hasn't kind of has no bags
you pick virgin okay you pick virgin
okay I guess next okay what about you me
I'm not gonna lie
it doesn't matter how many bodies you
got as a man men are very they like to
experience a lot of things in life so if
you're looking for a virgin good luck in
it no but not for real so you're looking
for the guy that's not a virgin no I'm
looking for a guy that can treat me good
dinner that can give me whatever because
you need experience to do that right
yeah so they're the guys I'm not going
for a bird I never said I would go for
it okay no I'm asking you guys guys are
the exact same wanna sexual experience
one doesn't who you picking I'm picking
the one with sexual experience thank you
I don't have time to teach yes
sorry sorry we can we can teach each
other on new things but I'm not right
the basics okay the basics everyone
knows
because you know what I'll go back what
do you mean
but virgins watch porn
no but you know what the corn is not
even close to sexual experience
if you look into corn you're gonna see a
woman with like you know perfect who had
a perfect but then when you see a woman
like a normal woman A working woman
every day you know she's doing nothing
you look at her and it's not even close
to what you see on the corn and you're
like hmm I don't know if I want to do
this you know but then you know what I'm
saying you got my point is the Virgin
knows something they don't know nothing
because they're virgins let me tell you
something
that is watching something and doing an
experience it's two different things
well I could I can watch the NBA but
that doesn't mean I know how to play
basketball well you're gonna understand
okay you know
I'll use my own experience I was 16. I
had watched corn at 16. I lost my
virginity at 16. when it came to
photographing my virginity I was nervous
as hell of course I don't know what the
hell I was I was like oh my God she's
coming and uh where's the condoms but I
had all of that going I like yeah but
wait wait what I'm trying to say is no
matter how much corn you've watched
being thrown into the situation is a
totally different thing so it doesn't
matter how much cost you watch well my
point is you're acting like a virgin
don't know uh
you're a hypocrite something
what if they get it you haven't spoken
personally when I lost my virginity
I'm not gonna write you I was so
embarrassed and I it was so different
from what I'd seen that I was completely
turned off so there was nothing nothing
happened nothing continued because
actually to be honest I was like no this
isn't this isn't quite for me but then
that also lets you know what you what
you like actually want to have during
sex like the the person's like what
they're like their body hygiene all
these things you don't even take into
account smells you've never smoked
before right you don't understand these
things until you actually go to do it
and if anyone has been on a corn set
they'll tell you it stinks but you don't
see that through the screen you can't
smell through the screen so they don't
always think see baby you got color
blocks you respected your time not
everyone's like you you know yeah
no but I'm saying have you been in a
concert of course not so how would you
know oh you're talking about corn do we
know oh yeah
okay but I'm just yeah I was just saying
that like I haven't been on a concert
but from my experience it's like no you
you don't realize what you're getting
into until you do it and as a man it's
it's so foreign for you that unless your
partner someone who's like really
engaging with you and open to
communication and actually is just happy
for this first experience to be open it
doesn't have to be good but just open
that's completely different
and what are women attracted to how many
times do you girls say we're attracted
to confidence how is a guy going to have
confidence if he has no idea what he's
doing yeah but it's a full confidence
there's a difference between being like
in the intermediate not known like
absolutely anything and just knowing a
little bit enough to kind of get you
started I feel like he's virgins in this
like box to say they don't know nothing
at all okay I'm not saying they're going
to be the greatest I'm gonna have the
highest amount of education on the fat
but they're gonna know something I just
I just don't know if you've really
interacted with virgins recently
um because I like I've gone to do you
know how to pick up artists about campus
so it's like basically men will pay
thousands of dollars to learn how to get
laid one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year it's very it's very hard for men to
get sex and you know talking to some of
these guys like a lot of them are kind
of awkward a lot of them are shy it's
not like a guy that's charismatic funny
like most of them can't even get you
into bed how the hell are they gonna
have confidence when they get you there
I feel like that's the extreme example
but this is the thing like it's not
extreme if men can't have sex they will
so like that's on a more niche market of
men I feel like most most men are not
that nervous
you know why she thinks that pill
because you're dealing with the top 20
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so what so what happens is right the
top you've been dealing with the top 20
of men all of your life 80 of men you
don't even know exist yeah 80 of men
that you walk in you go Starbucks you
walk down the street yeah they're
they're they're doing the um I don't
know the uh the stacking the shelves in
he was handsome whatever it was right
the top 20 of men you've been dealing
with all your life 80 of men you've been
dealing with So when you say no but men
are x y and said you're talking about
yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible